malekko room
hey
and then we need to share this over here
share the screen
yeah how
you
so it's on
deputies
alright
pressing testing one two three oh hell
yeah oh hell yeah welcome to another
episode of trying Ronnie game and if you
got to my
have anybody on the Hangout
okay yeah let's start it up
alright
you
oh hey welcome to the Friday review
everyone Friday review of games no
Friday review of apps today why because
i suck rachel meyer is not here today
and for whatever reason well it's not
just rato mia we are in a new place it's
actually Andy Rubens old office and I'm
not sure if it's malevolent ghosts or
possibly steve jobs from beyond the
grave just infusing this room with with
a sense of anti android sentiment but uh
everything just went to hell there's
there's no way to sugarcoat it yeah it
was kind of a disaster but but i have my
hard hat on so i'll be safe and
signifying that we are under
construction wait i need i need a it be
open otherwise this is going to be a
very unfortunate so we had were drinking
today this event tennis event eNOS how
do you pronounce that I don't know but
buys an eisbock so yup cheers ian I
think we need to drink more today than
we normally would oh and we're out of
focus very nice alright so gonna be
careful not to what is our Lord doesn't
know is we've replaced his regular beer
with ice beer at twelve percent alcohol
holy wow that's pretty strong basically
it gets any stronger than this and you
start bottling it in a dead squirrel
well this could be a very interesting
Friday review and we actually have a
whole bunch of games lined up for you
all and it's a it's a really good
collection I think a quap across a wide
spectrum we actually have a couple of
games that were previously featured on
google play but now i think we can talk
about the new versions and kind of
explain how featuring is changed a
little bit as well yeah so basically we
featured these games we think really
highly of them and I say that in prelude
to us completely ripping them apart on
the show today so why don't we start
chronologically with inotia three
children of carnea alright so knows you
three is AK RPG in
in the in the truest fashion and which
means for all of you viewers that like
all the other k rdp k RPGs it actually
is a bit of a retro game and that being
said the graphical quality and I know
she is really really very good for this
genre you can't see as much as we can
but on the tablet you know we it is it
is pretty highly pixelated but by
comparison to a lot of the work we've
seen in a genre it's really a level
above that some things to note it does
have a on the bottom you can see the
button of shame which we can see right
away over over there on the bottom of
the tablet the other thing we can we can
note is that this is very very much
designed around phone so you'll see that
when we actually go I don't want to do
new game that's so you don't know let's
continue my friend game the reason I
don't want to do a new game is the game
starts off in a flashback oh here here
is a fun part of the game where we're
supposed to kill cappy rain gear so this
was not a pita approved game I'm sure
but but the game is actually pretty fun
to play the thing about it on a tablet
you notice immediately is that the
controls are not actually scaled at all
to reflect a tablet surface so it's
actually this d-pad that you see here on
the left is actually kind of difficult
to use on a tablet you see I've really
got to move my finger an enormous amount
of distance the other thing to note of
course is it it's just kind of a low
resolution HUD and you know we don't
really expect someone to go through and
redo all of the graphics of the game you
know although I would love to see inotia
HD but it would be great to have at
least the the heads up display part that
users using interact with the title be
higher resolution so you know I think if
we looked at this game today we would
probably come you know the team would
probably contact them and say hey really
great beautiful-looking art but we
really want to see the HUD work better
on tablets we really want to to see it
be higher resolution so anything
anything else I want to add there no but
I do want to sort of emphasize what
you're saying here it's very very easy
um to look at something on a phone or or
even like it let's say a 7-inch tablet
and and it looks pretty crisp and clear
but once you get it up to 10 inch
is you're going to see these jaggies
you're going to see this blurriness and
that doesn't really affect the gameplay
and I'm not going to say that it makes
the game any better or worse but it does
affect your ability to get featured
because the Android featuring committee
takes tablets very seriously and we
definitely want to see things that are
made for tablets so yeah don't do what
our awesome awesome webcam just did and
make your graphics completely out of
focus another thing to note about this
game is it well while it is really great
to see this kind of content coming here
it would also be great to see it
actually getting a well while is it
information so you'll see that as i move
around i do have to move around the
d-pad when I pick things up i have to
pick things up with an action button and
all of this is kind of unintuitive if
i'm used to using everything else on the
tablet like being able to just tap where
I want to go being able to tap when I
want to pick things up like I would love
to just be able to tap on that gold and
pick it up but is that I have to walk
over to it and hit the action button so
there's a lot of things that could be
done with a little bit more work and I'd
love to see some of that happen because
I think that we're you know we're in a
transitionary period where there's all
this great older content with just a
little bit of additional love it could
turn from being something that is
appealing to kind of a nice genre to
something that has wider appeal and I
think this game is really fun and you
know maybe maybe killing reindeer isn't
everyone's cup of tea but you know I
think you get to kill like you all crazy
long haired Japanese bad guys later or
something probably yeah there's it I
suspect that reindeer two are not in
fact I know from experience reindeer are
certainly not the most tenacious enemy
you will face but I do think it's kind
of a funny thing that the game begins
with that with you having to battle
reindeer you're actually trying to get
reindeer leather by the way that's
actually the goal of the early or the
game also this is another thing that we
noticed is it when the game has an ad
obviously it's not really taking the the
size of the display into account so
you'll see that ad is really really
small in the middle of the screen yeah
another thing to think about with
tablets you know and actually a lot of
people do this you have the
the tablet ad be really really small
because it's the same size that's
supposed to be for a phone ad in inches
and while that may actually make your
users happier it certainly won't add to
your advertising revenue so something to
think about yeah exactly but you know I
think I you know overall this this was
one of my favorite k RPGs that I've
played on Android and it continues to be
one of the best available but I did you
enjoyed playing this sort of thing on on
you know the PlayStation Portable for
instance you'll love this game and the
controls and the scheme are actually
very similar but i think what Dan said
is important you can take something from
another platform like that you know like
a game console or handheld console and
poured it over directly and you'll
please a lot of people who liked playing
that game on that device but if you want
to please the general population of
smartphone users and tablet users you
might want to think about being a little
bit more touch friendly especially when
it comes to things that can be done far
easier with touch than they can with a
standard d-pad plus button style
interface absolutely and I and I again
you know this is I think this is one of
the best of the genre I do want to see
like HD versions these games come out
and I think as we as we as we go forward
we're going to see a lot more of that
but it's great to see really really rich
deep content like this coming to Android
you know kudos to compost for doing that
now so let's go to our next game we get
absolutely although before we do that I
did want to ask you dad assuming let's
say for the sake of argument that I'm a
young man we'll see is there a place
where I could go that I could you know
just feel you know IIIi didn't want to
actually put in a pitch for your local
YMCA here but you know given that i am
wearing this outfit and don't worry i
will not be taking off any clothing so
I'm just hoping we get to see policemen
an Indian chief at some point absolutely
Wow I'll work on that for the further
for the future again this was we are
under construction year and this is my
official android hardhat this actually
this hard hat and this vest actually
came from when we were building the
stand for mobile world congress
in barthelona this year so so this this
does have some good memories for me and
it's always nice to be able to reuse
stuff as I'm desperately searching for
new hats to wear i'm sure i love this
because dan dan's entire participation
in the construction of that booth was
installing the correct build of software
onto all the tablets and phones but he
did need a hard i didn't need a hard hat
to do that yeah I would I I don't want
to actually I wouldn't want to give them
mistaken in this leading impression that
I actually built the booth in any way
they just wouldn't let me anywhere near
the booth without a hard hat I think
knowing my accident prone nature that
was that was really what it came down to
knowing that I'd probably damaged
something else in the process so quite
true so should we talk about baguette
sure so also was featured on
google play and which i believe it was
android market at the time but it was
and i remember when it was featured
because I I remember having a phone call
with this developer while I was shopping
for cheese for my Thanksgiving dinner no
very good at the that's right foods in
Las Vegas which by the way they guess
not a big cheese town yeah it was a
little disappointing I think it all goes
to the high end restaurants and pretty
much doesn't go to the consumers pretty
much although I did get a fantastic
coconut milk Gouda that being said
though if you're looking for cheesy
stuff Vegas is really the place to find
it so you know I mean I I think it is a
completely different type of that's true
it's there's an irony there so I'm so
packet we love yes let's just say
you know this is right yeah that's right
I think it's Charlie price that does
this great little company they've got
some some great artists on staff so some
things to just a note is it a baguette
does have the button of shame on it and
and it's actually used in part of the
game so but in order to find out where
it's used you actually have to go click
on the Open think icon here at the top
and you'll see that that now I can
actually do this and it's actually
important for this particular release of
openfeint because it's actually the only
way to get to the openfeint settings so
please PLEASE openfeint which is now
agree please make another way of getting
to the settings because it's actually
very frustrating if someone actually
wants to play with an existing profile
this is the only way they can get to it
or change their profile name is
something that's
x y 3 2 4 5 1 x so it's very important
to actually so been available have yours
memorized minds to mine is not that you
can see on the screen but but the embody
might actually of my real accounting if
anyone wants to open paint me that's how
to do it um is that as I what is
friending you on open phages open
fainting you if it I I think so okay
it's either either data that's
collapsing in a heap in an open area i'm
not sure but listen the this brings us
back to a point that we've just many
times on the show which is you're
responsible for the contents of your APK
if you choose to use in a library that
breaks the rules and you don't get
featured it is your fault right it's
your problem so you know to our buddies
over at hidden variable we love this
game but we're not going to reef eacher
it until until that gets fixed I say
seemingly remembering actually that this
is on the feature list because because
we said oh yeah yeah these guys are fine
we don't need to retest them we better
go uh yeah makes a call but it in any
case these you know again this is really
nitpicking and you know we're not
necessarily going to stop something
being featured because it has this key
but but no I'm making a call right now
I'm picking up the red phone all right
whoa that's over there this is andy's
old office after all so the red phone
will actually read so what I actually do
something be careful when you pick up
the red film so that's baguette there's
a lot of really cool stuff they've done
with this UI I think this is a really
fun way that they've they've handled a
lot of their sharing I love the way you
change languages I mean there's really
just a lot of really cool stuff that
they've done here so kudos to hidden
variable the game is also very good I
don't even want to go into it you should
play it um it's a really really great
game you really should yeah it so it's a
great it's like a Tetris with feelings
yeah and honestly the you know this and
this is really how we want to game to
look on a tablet you can see it's just
crisp and clear the graphics are sharp
you really don't see any significant
evidence of scaling you know the game
the game really really takes very good
advantage of this transformer prime
tablet from any you see there aren't any
black bars around the screen you know
this really is an exam
of good design in terms of the layout
let's go to our next game it's an
excellent way to go through this this
week than normal the next game we're
going to look at I actually would you
want to pick because i'm not sure what
if we was an order I should be going in
this I have min on random order not well
let's go ahead and really quickly go
over the the second com2us game she
lovin break this up and break I don't
want to spend too long on up and break
at all com2us has a lot of different
teams and this one I think I think we
both agreed is a really nice creative
team but probably not their most
professional it says dev sisters
actually is the name of the team awesome
so yeah I i hope that really means that
there are women in engineering here
that's cool so a couple things to know
you know the CEO of come to us yeah
that's true actually so but just doesn't
universe pageant riding the games but
that's that's true well she never did
actually she just had dinner with her
and she said she actually I was a
consumer computer science major but it
dropped out as a sophomore to run com2us
literally she and she and her husband
it's got to be like 17 years ago now
dropped out of college and now they've
got like five thousand employees across
four five different countries you know
there there are a lot of stories about
people who come up with a great idea and
then drop out of school and there I was
not one of those people which is why I'm
here I have to dropping out of school
part right but not the great that's
right so um so one thing to note here
about oven break ginger brave run is it
first of all you can see that it does
have black bars on the left and right
hand side of the screen doesn't take up
the full screen it does not have the
buttons of shame though so there's a
kudos to the team therefore if we're
actually targeting the latest versions
of Android I have to admit the letter
boxing is really disappointing to me
because the game itself is really crisp
it's really well done it's obviously
been done with vector graphics you know
I it feels like they didn't have to let
her box it there is nothing there
there's nothing in the game or in the
graphics that would make me feel like
yeah letterboxing was a necessary choice
now what do we how do we feel about this
are you enjoying oven break you'll
receive a hundred gummy
reward if you leave a review right and
we are we're walking a fine line here
you're on the razor's edge here it is
immediately against policy to
incentivize a particular type of review
like to say you get 100 gummies for
leaving a five star review or leaving a
positive review that's a problem now
just incentivizing a review is not a
problem it's great that it's that you
want people to review your game well
just going to market got me the hundred
gummies which is always nice well and
that's that's the one thing is it you
know you can't actually yeah you know
call I back API to say I left a review
so it's one of those things where I
think it's a general rule you know you
are going to tell the you're telling the
user something that's that's patently
false and so because you write as you
can it was a lot more it was a lot more
egregious when people were saying you'll
get 100 gametes for a five-star review
that's true that's the um you know
honestly I'm glad to see some
incentivization of reviews at the
appropriate time in the appropriate way
the one thing that I do have to say
about this is they used the god awful
ugly old style android system a dialog
as a pop up for that and that was a
little disappointing let's go ahead and
take a look at the game so again the
game does run letterbox I don't really
see why I would say also on a tablet
especially the blur effect that you see
when I forgot I have to hold down the
slide button you can see I've completely
forgot to play the key how to play the
game in the last five minutes where I
have been looking at it so what I would
say is that for me the blur effect in
the background actually makes him give
me a little bit of I so you know I want
like a big Oh was that game hmm or like
braid you didn't like braid I did like
braid but I think it's because it was I
was watching it from a distance on my
television set hmm I'm clearly there
only two buttons I you know we're we're
not experiencing how much I actually
suck right now I playing games but um
the game is actually really not this
hard but apparently it's hard enough so
you know I mean it's an
endless runner there's a lot of endless
runner it actually it actually isn't an
endless runner there are only an end to
each level and there's different there's
multiple levels I I would call this I
would call this a run runner that's a
runner it's yet it's actually how many
endless run like truly endless runners
are there because I think most of the
games i call endless runners do you have
I have never seen is just that you're
always running yeah I've seen I mean
like I always think of it when I think
endless runners always think about robot
unicorn attack and there is this you
will eventually die the game tells you
that you know that you're going to be in
your doom so I well it is called adult
swim we don't want to sugarcoat life
well I know it's kind of rager in it
though that's that's that's actually
that's actually my favorite part about
the whole game so which which brings us
to our point you know there are games in
each genre that have been successful and
typically I I mean this isn't a hard and
fast rule but the one thing that you
wanted you is when you pick a genre when
you decide that you're going to make a
game in a particular genre make sure
that you at least meet the quality bar
of the genre that you're in you know in
this case it's a robot unicorn attack
game or it's a what's the other one that
that we oh god yeah there's there's been
a lot there's a bunch of it but anyway
you know I think you're making a jumping
game you better be better than doodle
jump if you make a ballistic physics
game better be as good as angry birds I
mean I think at the APEC fizzes onra I
actually think of wind-up Knight as
being as being kind of the the apt call
that I would call that a runner
absolutely you can't ever back up on
wine I'm not um you can only that you if
your character runs into something he
will turn around but anybody that you
have no control over the running you're
simply controlling the jumping in the
movement that's that's why that's why I
call it a runner but the apex of that
genre you in terms of quality I think I
think he did all right another hood
another couple of columns shout out
flattered and miss Pruitt I always prove
it so um anyways I but yeah this is a
really fun game I they did a really good
job that I'd love to see them take a
little farther I'd love to see them take
you no additional aspect ratios into
account its no that would be really
really really nice and it's it's so
close to being to being great and and
honestly you know it's a again I the
blur of fact it might be
if they could make it a little bit less
obvious on on tablets but you know again
that's it i mean it's it's definitely a
definite deal yeah it's a depth of field
they have a parallax it could be more I
do actually find what I'm looking at it
from this angle from this distance I
don't mind it when I was running at it
like this which is how I usually play a
tablet game you know then then I
actually notice it's also part of the
reason why I'm doing so terribly at it
not to make excuses let's go to the next
game absolute so I think I think we want
to say the saving private cheap for the
end just because the title is so funny
maybe people will stick around for us to
actually oh yeah absolutely it's it's
the perfect sheep did you succeed anyway
so here's the thing by the way we we do
want to get more viewers for this show
especially more live viewers so tell
your friends about us yeah especially in
your living friends as those ones we
want exactly or dead friends aren't very
helpful to I can't count them know
unless I'm up here which case man you
know they're sort of okay so um anyways
so what do we want to go to next well
let's take a look at weapon chicken I
think there's a little bit to be said
about that there is no weapon chicken is
using unity and yeah hello wait go back
let's stay back slit so you could switch
over Robert Lee by the way is doing our
tech today for it and doing a fantastic
yes Somali Robert is not on drugs of any
kind so he isn't drinking the ice beer
either although we did get one that or
this is some amazingly strong stuff yes
okay let's go ahead and launch this so
you'll see when we launched it you'll
see that it has this screen and actually
this was a bug in an older version of
the unity and it was and it simply you
made the the reason why unity had this
problem was they made the assumption
that if you loaded a PNG it would
actually load into a 16-bit bitmap and
the reality is if you're using bitmap
factory and you're loading a PNG it's
actually going to load into whatever the
operating system feels like if you don't
actually set some parameters on that and
so what ended up happening is it when we
went to ice cream sandwich we actually
made it always load 32-bit for the
highest possible rendering quality so
unfortunately he was there like a
Russian dude making this decision
actually he was friends yeah I thought
you're the highest
is possible entry question so uh so in
any case and so so yeah so we actually
worked this bug out with unity and they
they did update it and so my you know my
general guideline is with unity you know
trying to update your title to using the
latest version and you won't have that
trouble with ice cream sandwich as far
as the game itself it has some
interesting stuff in it this is a game
that has sharing built into it you can
see it's got papaya you know again if
you're using a shared library you have
to be very careful because as a general
rule shared libraries are going to be
something you're responsible for and and
the game itself is kind of cool I
there's a couple things I definitely
want to see more optimization for touch
I have two controllers with areas and
they actually are scaled pretty well on
this device which is nice although it
may I'm not sure if that's an artifact
of unity or an artifact of the game
design but that's pretty good what I
would love to see is being able to touch
anywhere on either side for the dual
controls I don't particularly what
technology has brought us lately the the
onward march of progress has decided
that you don't have to touch inside at
one specific circle in order to control
a dual six shooter game on android and
so those of you who are creating
dual-stick shooters should probably take
notice the but you know it's some other
things to kind of note about the title
I'd actually get you get a bit from
unity is a general rule one of the
things that it does that the later
versions actually do handle on this
version is new enough that it actually
automatically will handle the not
playing sound on the lock screen which
is cool whoa did we just lose just my
tablet just decided to say goodbye oddly
enough well and things we're going so
well I know it yeah well why while we're
doing that let's just check over with
Robert so Robert what is the the
livestream look like we have comments
are people saying things can people hear
us are people say oh there's a huge echo
or things soccer sorry nothing like that
no no one's saying anything all right I
get all the none of you that are common
said that's great do we have we're yours
it should it should say on the YouTube
page we're using we're using our
comprehensive Robert Lee based analytic
system here pull that up right that's
right so we're way to it we're waiting
for the tablet rebooted well that did
just completely stopped they didn't know
it did it that's half with just the boom
yeah boom well you know no it's kind of
unusual I that's we were about seeing
everything going on during this review
today I do believe in me oh you were
actually on the right page Robert you
you want to go to the yeah yeah the
analytics are underneath oh ok so we
have 33 be thank you all for a bit of
you and we love you so let's go back to
weapon chicken bola and will continue
get a lot of lot more views over the
weekend why this is a great weekend show
people you know they curl up with their
loved ones I get a lot of play time in
bars and I quality I think everyone is
playing diablo 3 right now that's why
they're not watching that is quite
possible you know it's funny on one of
our internal Google lists there's
actually a guy who said yeah by the way
I just spent three solid days playing
diablo 3 mmm really really how much you
get paid again okay so CA one of the one
of the things that unity does actually
not do for you is help to do this kind
of you I but it looks pretty good yeah
you know as a general rule you know that
I don't know if we want to go into this
but what happens if you press the guy
buy gold button but more importantly
let's let's talk a little bit more but
let's put it this way we are concerned
about this title and it's possibly in
violation of google play store policies
you know dan and I don't make that call
obviously yes we we are really concerned
that all of our developer partners make
sure that they're in compliance because
if you get banned it's sort of annoying
you trying get your account back it's
really it's not a good thing in this
case remember that google play store
policies require
you use only google play as a
monetization story for for in-app
purchases absolutely not so no no paypal
no random websites no stores owned by
other people if you distribute it on
Google Play you monetize through google
play if you distribute it in some other
way you know whatever android is an open
platform i think i'm salute that that's
the key thing and Google play's almost
as open as Android is no we we download
this particular game from google play
yes because we are chills for the man
and i we we found some issues the man
whose office this is 0 this is our
office it's been our office madness by
the way what you can't see i mean all
you can see is a is a white wall because
we were advised to you know stand
against something blank so that we would
pop more but surrounding us is a
veritable cornucopia thousands and
thousands of dollars worth of random
choice that that Andy left behind
because he didn't want them and the
effort of sending an email saying hey
come and get this stuff not too great
that's exciting actually but mostly what
mostly is in this office of are a bunch
of empty shells let's just make that
clear but they are beautiful there are
the shells which they look these are
hand handmade I'm convinced extruded
aluminum and and their their their app
so they're absolutely incredible I want
these shelves for my house you can yep
if you had a space shuttle yes you could
put it on these show absolutely I just
spread them out of it yeah I think I
think I think would actually hold that
much I mean holds monitors and other
other random things so yeah you're gonna
build out so little shells are awesome
and then let's not even get into what we
found in the drawers we won't get into
it let's just say they were historical
artifacts a great quality yes they were
they were we loved it thank you Andy so
um let's go on to no whiskey but no with
you is that all right we needed to this
let's move on oh what's roaring skies
roaring skies I like and you know why I
like it is because I it reminds me of a
sort of a weird real-time combination of
radon bungling Bay
steam birds with a little bit of earn
con set a mixed in okay now this game
also appears that it may be in violation
of some monetization policy so I you
know developers if you're listening by
the way the the name of this developer
brew engine does that take you back yeah
it definitely does definitely done it
doesn't take me back I you know I was
doing console during the brewery there
was a time when I was working on broom
and no but it was a cylot II it was a
sorry time it was this is it was in the
early days that was actually when you
really did have to do a build for every
single device and the reason you did was
that was actually with what what the
carriers and the required who you could
use brew and you actually haven't send
every single one of your titles through
QA with a with a with a professional QA
service so it was it was definitely the
dark ages and you know you certainly
they didn't understand the concept of
eighth for ya everything had to be paid
and and that and and the revenue shares
were actually not nearly as generous for
the developer as they are today back
then so it was it was definitely I think
you know we're in a much much better
time now certainly in just about every
way although an act to the versions of
brew that I worked on also did not allow
for multi-threading so we actually had
to use cooperative multitasking in our
games which really and everything you
wrote which was a very unfortunate and
challenging and actually we did an
incredible amount of kind of a
boilerplate red you know fiber mimicking
stuff in order to make that you do the
ola save the context and pushing pop it
and yeah we had like such up long jump
here and there set jump and long jump
was our friend we also did not have
exceptions among other things so yes in
a case let's go back to now the stop
reminiscing about the bad old days and
things don't always get worse that's
what that's what that's what that's
right back in my a time
so this is a this is a shooter or a
let's call it an endless shooter because
you don't stop shooting ever but you you
know you fly around and dogfight and
there's other people will join you there
on the internet and there are planes
that fight for you but are not
controlled by other players and things
get fast and frenetic there's also a
money system where you can land on your
carrier and buy extras all in all it's
it's a pretty fun game it has all the
elements of a fun game and I really
enjoyed playing it it it definitely
doesn't feel as polished as some of the
other ones we've seen mm-hmm well you
know any anytime you actually see a game
with an FPS counter on it you know that
it sort of feels like the little bit in
development you know that yeah this is
definitely a hacker game and and
indefinitely that's one thing I've
noticed is that the framerate does tend
to slow down on my device so you're
you're controlling it in a completely
different way than I did oh really yeah
so let me try so the way I controlled it
was by just compass points yes but you
were kind of like going all over the
place but it actually I was just I was
just using that to steer because you can
steer from all different positions of
the joystick that's a good point so if
you if you put your joystick on the
plane then you can just say this is
where I want to go but it hides my plane
I can't watch it being shot repeatedly
by everything that we shot these people
suck actually yeah I would say their aim
does not seem to be nearly as good as
the bullet pass would suggest although
it's possible that i'm indy i'm in the
i'm too chicken to actually play the
real version of the game you're you're
playing the helper burden i think so
yeah okay so well but yeah but what you
want to do is fly to your carrier and
then you can pick up some speed and some
range and other things that you know as
you did in World War two you had to buy
everything for your plane no I will you
know he'll nights did used to use the
more popular current term
a time of austerity and we work and we
were conserving everywhere we could and
so obviously you wouldn't be very well
equipped you have that you'd have to get
scrap from other planes bring that back
and then they would melt that down and
turn that into weapons for you so
clearly obviously we've we have time
compression going on here but this is
you know an attempt at extreme realism
really it is that that what it was I
thought that's our world war two work so
yeah it is but I mean this is a fun game
you know there's there's a bunch of
things I would fix like it you know
everything static textures so the sea
the land they're all sort of your
generic you know procedural textures
that came out of some random unix
command and the did I want to know that
unix command um you know the the the
hide is a little a little off but really
the gameplay itself and the way the
planes turn and and shooting each other
the AI and all the the little gameplay
pieces fit together really nice yeah
this game has a very high rating on the
google play store and i think it's well
deserved yeah there's a lot of really
cool stuff come in this game and i do
think you know once again you make sure
that you are reading through our
policies and other things to note about
this game it is full screen which is
nice and it's portrait version not
really sure why this game doesn't
support portrait and landscape to be
honest I think you can work easily well
in both and you know a lot of things we
kind of make the assumption that games
will not support landscape these days or
will not support portrait and will not
rotate but it's actually really nice
when a game does yeah I there's no real
reason for this game do you insist on a
particular orientation because the game
itself is all about turning your plane
every which way yeah so I would love
what I would love to see the you know
the author to I'd love to see them get
rid of the menu Shane I'd love to see
them make it a game that can rotate I
think that you know there's a lot
specially on that this tablet it looks
really good on the tablet if you're
really great if people could experience
it you know in in their tablet default
orientation which on you know Android is
typically on a landscape orientation yep
so let's go to our next title that would
be temp blocks I believe oh tap blocks
now this was interesting because tap
blocks actually had a had a strange
comment about it saying it was trying to
get people to buy Steph as far as i can
tell outside of
add it really doesn't do that but you
know I haven't played the game in
extreme depth tap blocks is a puzzler
and and so let's just let's just get
into the game the goal is you have to
you have to click on blocks that are
that more than three so there we are and
and and you try to find combination
serve your your standard match three or
more so this is this is sort of like the
old bubble breaker game that used to
ship with some of the old phones right
he's like you break the bubbles and what
you're trying to do is you don't want to
break them until there's multiples
because you get a combo right yeah
that's yeah and you know the goal the
goal is obviously be able to continue to
keep playing you know I you know and not
run out of break balls and the game also
helps you a little bit by giving you
these bonuses you see this one here will
break that entire row and and so that
was like a like a pickup type thing yeah
it was a special block so there's so
that's part of part of the way the game
actually helps you in this because they
gave me get you can get pretty
frustrating actually I'm trying to
figure out what you can break this block
is not going to help me at all what does
that look to that will break everything
in this row will help me minimally what
I'd like to do is get it to go a little
farther down perhaps where I where I'm
stuck so that was smart I was hoping
that I could get another i would get
some more blue pieces around there but
looks like I'm stuck actually using it
at that particular level but the idea is
they don't to obviate the bottom there's
a whole bunch of places where if they
get this to go a little bit lower i
might actually be able to help have it
helped me out a little bit more that was
not one of those places but yeah it's a
fun so there is some kind it has to be
at least three at least three well
that's tough yeah it's actually it's a
challenging and there's some definite
strategy whenever you miss one you see
your time actually gets goes down and I
don't know I think you buy back to us
into a corner here Bob well you know we
can always do that I don't unfortunately
I'll get us a little further and I would
say you know I I what the other thing
that's actually a bonus multiplier so as
we do about season order you like the
music actually turns up and then
eventually you get 2x bonus and probably
beyond that if you're really good we
were we were actually supposed to have
music this time
what happened to that I not 400 I think
I I'm screwed it up earlier yeah he was
I got that can be said of so many other
I think we're just really happy that we
have sound with us today theoretically I
mean nobody's complaining about it but
we could just have 33 masochists on it's
possible as possible you know you know
we are it's possible in our show
actually after all the audio problems we
have is actually only you know really
appealing to the hearing impaired it
this possum you know which and we do
actually go through after this and write
relent and and it auto captions it and
if you ever want to read something
really really amusing we definitely
recommend you look at what with the auto
captions with the auto connecting
software does last year it was just I
mean it was it was it was comedy
actually I think we should read that
auto caption it but I there we are the
the brainchild of many of many at Google
research researcher and it is does
produce comic results well it's you know
it's it's not as bad as some things no
not as bad as all not as bad as a
trouble we've had actually putting this
Friday review together I think I think
that yeah I think it they the far more
successful there right but again you
know there's this is this is very simple
it's got the ability for move as within
the game which is great it really is you
know it I I didn't have any real issues
with this game no I mean there's a few
you know things that we've talked about
before right so there's some share
buttons here that it would probably be
better to actually just do a standard
Android share button because remember
that way you get not just the standard
you know Facebook etc you get the things
that your user actually uses to share so
when the next reddit or facebook or
myspace or whatever comes along you're
not going to be left behind or needing
to update absolutely i mean if they
really want to share their gaming
experience on linkedin i say by gum let
them do that hat is exactly what i do
all the time you're right post my high
scores yeah in fact it's we won't hire
somebody that doesn't have a gamer score
more than 10,000 it's a good news it's a
good thing that i actually think i think
my camera is off you slipped in that
yeah you said it i got in i think my
gamerscore is right but you know the sad
thing is though is what is your
gamerscore compared to the number of
games you bought that's that's a good my
gamerscore is just an edge over 10,000
mm-hmm I own more than 100 games because
I used to work for Xbox right right I
which if you do the math is pretty lousy
every every game is like that you
basically started every game Frank it
happened more or less yeah you get 50
gamerscore exactly exactly it's tough
well you know it's because I spent all
of my time playing the elder scrolls
oblivion yeah I and pretty much that was
that was actually for me it was it was
geometry wars hey you know what the
really really sad thing is I never got
all the achievements on geometry I'll
tell you why it was freaking you know
ossible that is reason you just can you
you really didn't have a good supply of
oh ok I can't actually say it on your
nose yeah I I think I think I think you
were you didn't have the right
botanicals yet i'm saying i think i
think you know i actually i actually
hawaii i know that i believe that it
would take it would take something that
was equivalent to a massive dose of
caffeine would be my really my only hope
right as you're worse yeah all i know is
the the kids at the college where i used
to teach i would share these very
interesting snacks with me and then they
were the only people i knew that could
really a ste ama tree were so there we
are there we are yeah i think i think
i've managed to get maybe 80 out of 100
available gamerscore or something like
that yeah so that and then you pour like
500 hours into it yeah you much by the
way so this ice block is strong very
strong yeah this is like the the port of
yours mm-hmm which you know you don't
see that by the way you don't see uh
beers where they actually arrest the
fermentation with the addition of
whiskey but that sounds like an
excellent idea doesn't it mm-hmm well
Gary so I'm here what it actually says
in the back of the bottle then mfn
tennis I don't know how you pronounce
that has been known to be the most
intense and complex wheat doppelbock in
the world this was the case in the past
but not anymore recently hans-peter
drexler brewmaster at g schneider and
saw and learned heard stories about some
extra special event at the tennis
resulting from partial freezing during
cold winter transport in the 19th
30 s he decided to to recreate this
mistake to further concentrate the beer
and here is what we have this mistake
yes mistake so I'm good other one guys
the way you make Applejack right up
right right exactly let's continue on
with actually looking at gayness so
we've either weapon chicken we looked at
roaring skies believe this only thing
left is saving products private sheep
and and I I really wanted to launch I
maintain sounds like something that came
out of San Fernando Valley so this is
about by our buddies at ama they partner
with papaya for this one I xxe Googlers
papaya mmm it's a really interesting
concept and the execution is really
excellent in a lot of ways I think the
way we felt those it's just a little
uneven so here's how the game works you
have a sheep who is Pentagon shaped and
refuses to help himself I guess because
he's a private but as soon as you get
him on to quote unquote dry land mm-hmm
he leaps up and salutes you yes and you
know this game obviously has like a
whole bunch of classic things that you
know that we've talked about in the past
one of them is obviously it has giant
black borders on either side yeah
Blissett is a letterbox aspect ratio she
also has the Zoom button I want to press
this just to see what happens let's zoom
to fill screen I and of course the game
closes that's not surprising Burt
village yeah those what's going on most
games actually don't have the ability to
handle screen sizes that change they all
should now what the hell you're actually
seeing is that the graphics are totally
unchanged when we zoom in and the reason
why is they're very very low quality in
fact it's possible the graphics are
actually higher quality now when we're
zoomed in this way well that does
sometimes happen and the reason is that
the full screen is an mdpi whereas the
compatibility mode emulates an HTTP I
device or a different DPI device
actually I'm not really sure which one
it is and then zooms you out and so
sometimes the game will select different
resources based on that and they'll
actually be higher quality yeah
sometimes its interests
usually it's just because the game is is
stretching in different ways but but but
so this game is an example of also
having the menu button of shame and it's
actually important for papaya so this is
once again a case in which having a
third party libraries preventing you
from really doing the right thing
however the zoom buttons easy to prevent
and you don't need to do that you don't
actually need to have papaya to do that
this you just need to target a
reasonably high SDK version or to get
rid of there as well and and or make
sure you support recent you know
multiple screen sizes so I'm talk about
a pie in this game this is uh this is
also one of these cases in which papaya
actually does a bunch of stuff in this
game that just cause the game to not
work very well and so it's really
important when you integrate these
third-party libraries to try to make
sure that they're actually they're
actually doing something right like I've
had papaya pop up something in the
screening that I couldn't get rid of and
I had to close the game and all sorts of
stuff so it's very very you know i think
that i know it's tricky to write a
third-party library but it's very very
important to test all those
functionalities and now let's let's be
really clear about one thing we really
enjoy third-party library we think that
it's very important they have a vibrant
ecosystem system of social gaming I you
know it's great to see games forming
networks it's great to see people
playing with each other it's just a
matter of making sure that these things
actually work on the Android platform in
the way that users are going to expect
and want and if the game doesn't work
well or if it pops up things at
inappropriate times maybe your game
wakes up at some random time and covers
up your phone call or cover up your your
web browser your email these are all
things that make users upset it's it's
not it's not about us and what we think
it's that the users are not going to
like it and that's a problem with a lot
of middleware as Dan said it's very very
difficult and you would know right i
mean you wrote a library that is now
being included a lot of games are for
download
and I remember you know uh I remember
distinctly that you said oh yeah we'll
have that done in a week and I had told
some people haven't done in a week and
then they came back and they wanted to
lynch me and I'm like Dan still working
on it but the truth is it was just
really freaking a heart yeah you know I
think I think that you know ultimately
in this particular in this particular
case a lot of the time is it you know it
just has a developer tested their
library against the latest versions of
Android and you guys as a developer your
kind of drag departed dragged you kind
of dragged along these libraries
especially if they're closed source
right and you know to me that's always
you know I have a under version 2 using
closed source libraries as much as
possible just because I feel like I'm
stuck you know I like I'm trap and I
can't fix things and I feel like you're
a Windows developer at that point yes
that's exactly what it would say that's
what is worried about working on windows
like it just wasn't my fault man that's
true actually yeah I actually feel more
directly responsible when I'm working on
on inch right than I did when I had it's
true that I can always go fix the source
man yeah exactly so in any case uh so
yeah that's just one thing to note about
this game but you know it's a cute
concept I would love to see higher
resolution artwork I think that you know
honestly if you're coming out over a
year after angry bird shipped you should
use that as your bar you know that's you
know when you're when you're putting
together any kind of physics puzzler you
know say look it's got to look at least
as good as angry birds it's got to have
at least as high resolution graphics as
something like zeptolab amazing game of
that I can't remember the name got the
Rope cut the rope thank you you know
like you know those are that's kind of
that's kind of the bar now and I'm going
to me if you're trying to if you want to
compete in the big leagues those are the
games to shoot at least in terms of
graphical fidelity against and I feel
like these people did a pretty good job
i mean there's the RCB definitely
there's a few points where I'm like wow
that's a really stellar animation or
that's really stellar artwork but in
general you know especially I think part
of it was the pentagonal sheep that does
nothing I don't think he even blinks
yeah and i think i think you know part
of part of that is like i should get the
feeling that he's afraid you know
obviously he's a pentagonal sheep you
know they should have some character and
also though just just like the
text is really low resolution you know a
lot of the graphics are really low
resolution you know it's like this looks
like it was designed for a phone of two
years ago and yeah honestly we're no
longer there that is a really big
problem in all the devices this year
that are hi ender are shipping at 720p
asus announced a 1080p tablet you know
it's just gonna get worse yeah that in
that sense and I mean I mean the thing
is is it you know this game really has H
vga graphics this is not even designed
for apples but this is sign for the
phone what's really tough about it too
is that I believe these graphics were
originally sourced as vectors yeah if
you look at Italy's look like they were
come they came out of illustrator or a
similar vector program a lot of them do
at least um yeah and and that's where
you want to probably actually keep the
vector artwork and bring it so you know
for instance bouncy mouse did this and I
think baguette did it to where you you
actually keep the artwork in illustrator
or an SVG or one of these other vector
format and then render it out for the
appropriate display size when you bring
in it or even use the Android vector
engine if that works for you yeah I what
I mean I definitely this would be a good
target for doing something in OpenGL you
know you could certainly do that the
problem with OpenGL is that you're going
to want to take advantage of
anti-aliasing so you want your if you
use up opengl to render you're going to
want to render to a surface and then and
then rescale it so it's not a perfect
solution for opengl but definitely you
know and there's even little things like
i love the fact that he's actually
balancing on this on this tower here but
I'd kind of love to be able to kind of
mess with him like and I definitely
wanted to not to see ya know you're just
asking for you know I know I know oh
yeah both words but I think I think that
really if this actually sweated money
every now and then but i but i think
that in terms of like the level when we
get to these puzzlers the level that
their engagement there now demanding i
think these are the kinds of people
should think about you know it's how to
make everything feel really interactive
right and well you got some tough
competition out there right I and you
should remember that I mean that the
truth is I this year you know sedan and
I connect with a lot of game partners
and this year the people were talked to
most are coming from playstation network
and
PLA so you've got people that are used
to programming xbox live games used to
programming PlayStation games and
they're coming into this market and
you're really gonna have to up her game
I think yeah quite literally and you
know again this is a you know it's it's
oh look at that what what happened I is
that I actually what a way to do I look
that's kind of cool I like this game
sense of humor it's cool it does have it
does have a really good sense of humor
so I was trying to try this see if this
actually helped here looks like it looks
like that will work better there you go
so uh uh but any cans of the pop out
sheep of that guy tells me every dive I
know I know it's it's it's it's it's
very impressive I you know don't know
another sheep that could do that all
right since the alcohol is starting to
take effect I think it's time for us to
be wrapping up our session is you know
you when you've had half a beer and
you're feeling like okay I'm I've had
two or three you know that that's
something great that is yes I heard
equivalent of about three beers and that
in that model yeah exactly alright so um
thank you once again for joining us for
the Friday review we're again coming
live from Andy Reubens former office
here in building 44 we're actually
overlooking the Android statuary out in
front which is a very exciting it's
great to see we see people taking
pictures out there certainly if you're
in mountain view you're welcome to come
by go in front of the statues and take
pictures it's very fun they're very cool
looking they're made out of there you
know giant things of foam so they're
other fun just don't step on them and
every now and then they float away yeah
we actually we did have we did have a
great time during a rainstorm where
everybody aquarium a canoe became a
canoe but it is great to be here and
hopefully we'll get to be here every
weekend we're going to try to suck even
less next week we are actually we do
have a budget we're gonna buy some slow
do light oh yeah we got some studio
lighting on me the works like a Mraz
coming we've got that yes this thing
that you bought at Home Depot that you
normally use to pay that was an
incredible value i might add
and honestly these webcams are pretty
awesome for webcams I'm free for webcams
yeah yeah I'm not you know go go webcam
developers but any case yeah I you know
I think I think the goal is we're gonna
try to get get get funky with this and
yes you saw it is a real there's lots of
action that's going right here on this
show you know we're getting about 5,000
views a week and we want to get up
20,000 so let us know what's wrong let
us know what you think that we should do
yeah you know doing more entertainment
do we need do we need more special
guests doing it more comedy do we need
less comedy do we need less Daniel but
you know that I don't know that I'm just
spitballing do we need more beer let us
go we need less fear let us know so
actually if we need less beer don't
mention that effort if you wouldn't mind
we got to keep this thing going that's
right that's true and actually after
after after the the technical challenges
we had putting the show together today
in our new facility i would say that
things did not go well we shall i
started drinking exactly we did we proof
positive i can go all right it's been
great you guys are so the friday a
preview will be back next week with the
same slate of apps because we know that
everything got completely screwed up the
friday game review will also be back
with a different slate of games so
please make sure that you go to our
moderator page and vote on what you'd
like to see let us know if there's
anything we could be doing better or if
there's anything you liked or didn't
like and other than that we will see you
next week so so long take care and have
a great weekend
you